sehr geehrte frau bundesminister im
hintergrund stets die all whites drei
den über ein halbes jahrhundert treue
dienste geleistet hat ihre zeit ist
gekommen jetzt dank ihnen haben wir in
weiser voraussicht einen schönen neuen
hubschrauber nämlich die a b 169 m und
auf die freuen wir uns sehr die wird
viel für die österreichische bevölkerung
und für das österreichische bundesheer
leisten in den nächsten jahrzehnten sind
sie nicht der meinung dass dieses a w
169 eben doch ein bisschen sperrig
klingt der oberstleutnant sie haben
sowas von recht
wir freuen uns auf den neuen
hubschrauber dialekt unglaubliche
dienste geleistet aber der name ist
wirklich ein bisschen sperrig was
wollten sie dafür eine ausbeutung war
man einfach sagen freunde des
bundesheeres suchen wir durch einnahmen
aus boston stunden endlich vorschläge
mit trennungs drauf und wir freuen uns
auch darauf die piloten des
österreichischen bundesheeres